the guy who directed underworld a new
writer too is the draw of anna de almost
enough to bring in dedicated john wick
fans or will the spin-off flop here's
why fans are worried when john wick
first arrived in theaters back in 2014
the keanu reeves vehicle turned out to
be a breath of fresh air in a sea of
middling action thrillers the simple but
effective revenge plot is emotionally
compelling enough that it allows
audiences to get behind wick as he
slaughters mobsters with varying degrees
of brutality combined with colour
direction from notable stunt
coordinators chad stehlski and david
leach it's the rollicking movie that
packs a genuine punch yeah i'm taken on
back from there the franchise flourished
as john wick's chapter 2 arrived in 2017
and john wick chapter 3 parabellum
swiftly followed in 2019. the third film
raked in just over 327 million dollars
worldwide so it's unsurprising that
lionsgate quickly gave to helsky the
green light to work on john wick chapter
4 which is set for release in 2023 and
of course there are also a few other
john wick projects in the pipeline
including a tv show revolving around the
continental hotel and a spin-off movie
known as ballerina the feature film will
follow one of the ballerina assassins
who briefly show up in parabellum and is
said to star knives house and no time to
die alarm anna de armas in the lead role
lionsgate recently confirmed that the
movie is supposed to start filming later
this year but john wick fans already
worried about the spin-off of course the
news that ballerina is said to start
filming later this year obviously has
some fans excited about diving back into
the john wick universe but others are
concerned about who's attached to the
project the film is directed by len
weisman who's best known for helming two
of the underworld movies as well as live
free or die hard and the 2012 remake of
total recall the middling quality of
these movies has fans skeptical about
what's ahead in the next chapter of the
wick verse as one redditch user recently
posted i like underworld but those
movies got worse and worse these guys on
the same project screams mindless action
movie meanwhile another user voiced
their concerns about the involvement of
john wick chapter 3 and army of the dead
writer shea hatton they said hatton and
wiseman films are not typically films i
get hyped about i like john wick 3. so
if the fourth one is solid hata may have
found his niche but tatan in combination
with wiseman gets me worried however
it's entirely possible wiseman has
changed his directing style since
underworld and a good example of his
better work is a live-action swamp thing
series he served as a director for the
first two episodes as well as an
executive producer on the series so it's
entirely possible that he could bring
some interesting flair to ballerina
regardless of how you feel about
wiseman's involvement the john wick
series has been solid so far so there
are many more reasons to be excited
about ballerina than there are to worry
first and foremost anna de armas has
firmly established herself as one of the
most exciting actresses working today
and fans have come out in full support
of her casting as one redditor says i
would watch this woman do her taxes but
it's not just redditors showing some
love towards diamonds on twitter one
user wrote anna de armas is starring in
the john wick's spin-off ballerina
that's all the information that i need
about the project i'm sold it's like
destiny that we were meant to meet
no doubt part of that excitement came
from the actress's role and no time to
die in which she played a gun-toting cia
agent many people seem to see her
casting as an extension of that
action-packed role one for example
tweeted hollywood remember the fun part
of that james bond movie alright how
about we do a whole movie about that
it's important to note that since it
hasn't even begun filming we're not
going to see a ballerina trailer for
some time clearly there's still a lot
left to be revealed about this latest
project and for now it might just be
best to keep an open mind after all if
any franchise can pull off a pleasant
surprise it's john wick
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]